in Spain the clocks tick differently as
Juan Rivera knows only too well Rivera
is a watchmaker in the Galician town of
TUI on the Portuguese border Chiodos
allows of my nose jun 22 and the Sun
hasn't even reached its zenith here from
the sun's position you think it was
about 11 am-10 throw out doghouse no
suppose I lost all the sale of a saucy
Spain runs on central european time
despite lying far to the west that means
the Sun is two or three hours behind the
clock many think spain should switch to
the same time zone as Britain or
Portugal which are an hour behind
central european time that situation
annoys watchmaker Rivera here in the Far
West of Spain the discrepancy between
the official time and solar time is
particularly great and he needs to
remember the one hour time difference
between Spain and neighboring Portugal
if he's to avoid arriving late for
business appointments there tampoco
tiene mucho sentido time difference
makes no sense here at the border
galicia is geographically in line with
portugal we have to have the same time
fidencio oh but it's nonsense for us
here porque es su casa aqui para
nosotros issue but spain and portugal
haven't always been in different time
zones Joaquin Alvarez is 92 as a young
man living under the Franco dictatorship
he remembers his country changing to
central european time that was in order
to be in the same time zone as Nazi
Germany it was a purely political
decision I don't lot of it my orders
yeah biblical bleed the orders came from
on high and you had to obey them there's
oblivia you were put under a lot of
pressure back then if you opposed
anything like a lovable cool it wasn't
like today when you
talk about anything so people were
forced to adopt this time you know that
I couldn't live with me unless Laura and
that was that bundle watchmaker Rivera
thinks it's high time for that decision
from the franco era to be reversed why
should people still be setting their
watches according to a whim of the
fascists it remains light hours after
Rivera shuts up shop in the evening
that's why he goes to bed late like most
spanish people but he has to get up in
the dark the watchmaker believes the
Spanish are suffering from sleep
deprivation because of the timezone
problem he envies the Portuguese they
also dabbled with central european time
but they decided to switch back 20 years
ago is that okay just young come they
change the time zone because it's better
for them that way the Portuguese are
more confident than we are more
traditional they're better in that
respect so is it time to follow in their
footsteps
if the majority of Spanish politicians
have their way spaniards could soon be
turning back their clocks no doubt that
would please their neighbors in Portugal
azules by the Spaniards change their
clocks to our time it must mean that
Portuguese time is advantageous meter 10
but Rivera isn't holding his breath he
knows change is often slow in coming it
doesn't us progeny a few projects
actually get implemented aced and
perhaps this will be one of them faith
tested but because it's not actually
costing anyone any money they'll
probably leave it as it is but the
watchmaker knows 76 years after the
introduction of central european time
here he and his countrymen will continue
to lead lives largely in accordance with
the Sun no matter what time zone there
in
you